l'événement politique de ce mercredi ce
soir sur antenne 2 après ce journal à
l'heure de vérité
l'heure de vérité avec comme invité
monsieur valéry giscard d'estaing
monsieur le président bonsoir bonsoir
plusieurs députés du parti républicain
et le bureau de l'udf souhaite vous
demander d'être candidat à la présidence
de la commission des affaires étrangères
de l'assemblée nationale alors ce poste
semblait promis à monsieur bernard stasi
serez-vous candidat le prend dans tous
les gros vont vous permettez d'abord de
souhaiter la bienvenue à mon ami helmut
fritz je suis très heureux qu'il faut
avec nous ce soir et c'est le symbole de
l'amitié franco allemande pour l'union
et la paix en europe
un mot sur votre question c'est
simplement ceci vous savez que tous les
ans la direction des des commissions et
renouveler à l'assemblée nationale et
donc c'est un événement qui aura lieu au
début d'avril ayant pollué d'anticiper
sur une échéance naturel qui est celle
du début d'avril
s'il bureau de l'udf qui est compétent
pour ces désignations propose d'être
candidat à la présidence de la
commission des affaires étrangères je
lui répondrais oui pourquoi pour deux
raisons d'abord parce que c'est une
commission qui est un rôle important
dont l'avis du parlement elle réunit à
la présence de trois anciens premiers
ministres il y a
raymond barre laurent fabius et pierre
mauroy et puis surtout à cause de son
sujet parce que cela peut être utile
pour l'action dont j'espère que par leur
ont tout à l'heure que je compte
poursuivre pour l'union de l'europe
merci monsieur le président
effectivement vous retrouverez à l'heure
de vérité dans quelques minutes vous
avez tenu à inviter à avoir à côté de
vous effectivement le chancelier ouest
allemand monsieur helmut schmidt ancien
chancelier me bonsoir monsieur le
chancelier
je voudrais vous poser une question qui
concerne la présidence européenne on
sait que monsieur valéry giscard
d'estaing a souvent et ni ses faveurs
pour cette présidence êtes vous
favorable à cette présidence européenne
et puis question adjacentes êtes vous
favorable à la candidature de valérie
giscard d'estaing
je crois qu'un jour il y aura un
président européen
tout d'abord ils se revoient clairement
au caisson s'est agi direct qu'il irait
directement tels que la position dans ce
cas là on doit lui fixer des tâches très
précise et très claire
en d'autres termes est ouverte et 12
pays se mettre d'accord
je trouve que c'est une bonne idée que
le premier président tel auprès de
pierre notte européenne soit le français
est bien entendu je serais battue qui a
entre eux
si un de mes amis français se trouvaient
près exercer cette fonction et s'il est
élu il aurait de toute façon mon appui
merci monsieur chancelier d'avoir
accepté de répondre à nos questions vous
retrouvera sans doute dans l'heure de
vérité dans quelques minutes et vous
pourrez téléphoner svp voici les numéros
pour rejoindre svp de paris 47 87 contre
11 cents un an auparavant
jean-louis le sun se fera un plaisir de
répercuter vos questions à monsieur
giscard d'estaing l'invité de l'heure de
vérité